بماذا او ما هو نقدك
لكتب التاريخ القديمه السعوديه وما هو ثم
ساذني بسؤال اخر ما هو رايك بمناهج تناول
التاريخ السعودي لكن لماذا تنتقد الكتب
القديمه هو الانتقاد في في محاوله التغذيب
او تصوير هذه المنطقه انها قامت على ان
الناس كانوا يعيشون في جهل وفي كفر وفي
ايضا شركيات وغير ذلك ونحن نقول للاسف
الشديد من كتب هذا الكلام وابتداهم بهم
المؤرخ حسين بن غنام عندما كان في الاحسن
قديمه الدرعيه فحاول ايضا ان يضيف في
كتابه هذا تدوينا او سيره للشيخ محمد بن
عبد الوهاب فيدون السيره الشخصيه ولا يدون
سيره الدوله ولهذا نجد في كثير من الوقائع
حتى في ذهاب الامام محمد بن سعود وفي
جهادي وايضا توحيدي لهذه البلاد مثل ما
ذكرت انه لا انه لا يشير ايضا ان الامام
اتجه لبلد بسبب وجود قبر او بسبب صنم او
بسبب كذا هذه للاسف الشديد اسقطها ابن
غنام
[موسيقى]
ولهذا للاسف الشديد يعني المناهج
التاريخيه في فتره من الفترات وصفت هذه
المنطقه بانهم يعيشون في الشرك ويعيشون
ايضا في جهل حتى قدم الشيخ محمد
ابن غنام في هذا الجانب ولقد الحقيقه نقد
مهم جدا فيقول المبالغات هذه الزائده يجب
ان يكون الباحث مثل المنصف مثل القاضي اذا
اراد ان ينظر لامر لا بد ان بشكل موضوع
وليس بشكل صحيح دعائي